servus kids und herzlich willkommen zum
ersten teil des 20 specials und zwar
befinden wir uns gerade auch nicht auf
irgendeinem server sondern auf dem
server auf dem max braun und ich doch
unser kleines projekt gemacht haben
den habe ich mir relativ skin
vorstellung ausgesucht gekriegt jetzt
neben den skins die das erste special
sein werden zu 20.000 abonnenten für die
ich mich ganz herzlich bedanke hiermit
auch nochmal dieses wunderschöne haus zu
sehen ein bisschen diese welt hier man
folie koopmann protection ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba so und wir sagen wir legen die lag
direkt los lassen sie uns direkt
loslegen direkt wenn eckig ddp direct
die indirekt dafür bitte ich meinen
assistenten jason hier ist man raus
wolfskin nur eins ist captain america
seht ihr hier oder erst captain america
ersten america auch ein sehr schönes
kinder mit diesem stern de auf der
berufszeit an der branche die es jetzt
jetzt jetzt übrigens im hintergrund das
ist ja das ist maxi fährt und das ist
ein anderes fertig hatte ich auch mal
ein gillette ab die die date up de smet
fährt man aber ist gestorben
direkt ganz genau so weiter damit kind
nummer zwei und zwar ist das kein
geringerer als doktor escape zeig dich
nice ein kleiner arzt gehen wenn es ging
kombiniert mit dem eines arztes hier mit
dem kreuz auf der brust und dem elend
background besorgt sein eis geworden
finde ich wie viel skins enthält das
pack insgesamt sieben skins wenn man an
sich glaubt sogar 97 oder sogar neuen
skins also es gibt einiges zu sehen für
euch heute deswegen werde ich auch die
vorstellung der einzelnen skins relativ
kompakt halten und wir gehen direkt
weiter zum dritten weiter im text kinder
drei ist der es die no 1 dino
wunderschön und nummer 44 bis ende mai
dürfen war nicht so schlau denn nummero
quattro und bevor ich weitermachen noch
eine info es gibt natürlich einen
download link unten in der beschreibung
da könnt ihr die gesamten skins die
heute in dem video gezeigt werden
downloaden es sind ich hab noch mal
nachgeschaut acht skins plus meine alten
und hier sehen wir
eur 4 mein alters gehen aber mit nicht
mit den blauen akzenten sondern mit gelb
gelbes trikot gelbe dinge am sieger der
blaue skins zu schlecht ist der kann
gerne zu diesem games in gräfenberg
zombies 542 gibt ihm respekt und das
kind nur morawski 05 liebe leute statt
gelb gibt es jetzt grün für euch hier
broilers kein grünes trikot grüne laster
hinterkopf von hühner akzente
quasi der blaues gehen diesmal mit
grünen akzenten und dieses ganze skin
pack ist wie gesagt insgesamt da erst
mal um euch so ein kleines geschenk
geben zu können so als kleines
dankeschön und darüber hinaus natürlich
dass hier auch in ganz vielen
verschiedenen formen und farben
die zugehörigkeit für leute hier ist die
nummer sechs für euch wenn ich nicht
ganz verzählt habe der rotes gehen
wieder prinzip schema des blauen skins
nur oder gekommen zombie achtung mit
roten elementen rot ist oft noch richtig
richtig coole farbe passt auch sehr gut
zu diesem design
es war eine wunderschöne habe er lassen
sie uns weiter mal vermied es ging 7
so leute skin nummer 7 müsse das sei
nicht moslem sad day damit ihr nicht die
ganze die zombies ungarn
hier seht ihr sg07 den logischen sk mit
elementen von logos gehen einfach
definiert so bitte wie er von dem von
dem alten logos kein korrekter weise
alle die sowohl logo als auch mitfeiern
können dass mit diesem logischen es kaum
ausdrücken der aber auch an sich auch
ziemlich ziemlich cool ist verbrannt
zombie okay ist kino zum abschluss
sollte last but not least der
allerletzte skin und zwar der klassische
es keskin sowie in kent in blau das pace
das baseboard über sage ich dass
basketball trikot
die goldkette nummer 9 hier hätten alle
elemente in blau gehalten die
schweißbänder pipapo streifen auf der
hose auch in blau also mit sehr viel
liebe zum detail gestaltet wie gesagt
heute der link für diese skins ist in
der beschreibung ich würde mich freuen
wenn ich in den nächsten tagen öfter
als kinder sehe oder irgendwelche
abwandlungen ich hoffe der erste teil
des 20 ratsbeschluss hat euch gefallen
weitere teile werden folgen ihr könnt
auch gerne mal jason checken ich glaub
ich verlinke euch den mal und in der
beschreibung
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
schreibt einfach mal eure meinung zu den
skins und in den kommentaren was haltet
ihr davon
und ihr biss dann job